You just made your first workflow. As you
saw, workflow actions fire depending on some kind
of event or trigger. When Barack Obama was
campaigning for the President of the United States, he
used salesforce. How might he had used workflow
rules in his campaign. Let's say someone signed
up to volunteer for his campaign. Maybe an
e-mail would be automatically sent to the new volunteer.
Or they could create a set of tasks to ramp up the new volunteer. Or possibly
they could use the volunteer's location to decide which campaign manager to
notify. Now Samantha and Andy will show you how to use approval processes, to
define a sequence of events that involves
human interaction in the decision making process.